when Hoda's daughter wasn't feeling well
I just wasn't there for her the way I
wanted to be Jenna Bush Hager breaks
down in tears on The Today Show
admitting she wasn't there for her
friend and co-host when Hoda copy's
three-year-old daughter Hope was
hospitalized earlier this year people
say the Today Show is a family and it
seems like a cliche but it's true Hoda
is like a sister to me like a lovely
wonderful you know presence in my life
every single day the emotional moment
aired on Wednesday's show during a chat
about brutal honesty I just wasn't there
for her the way I wanted to be and I
didn't know how to be so I and I felt
terrible about it but I didn't know what
to do so I just said it I said I feel
like I haven't been there for yeah as
for Hoda she praised Jenna for keeping
it real it was first of all one of the
most beautiful statements and it touched
me deeply and it meant everything to me
that you said that back in February the
today anchor was mysteriously absent
from the morning show for more than a
week we can tell you that Hoda's okay
she's got a family health matter that
she has been dealing with Tom yamas and
Craig Melvin subbed in for Hoda
alongside Savannah Guthrie while Willie
Geist and Chanel Jones filled in
alongside Jenna for Hoda's fourth hour
gig I think we're kind of there for each
other they always say like morning
television is a special ecosystem we all
kind of get each other we get our lives
and so you need to be able to have a
family Hoda returned to the show in
March and gave fans a little insight
into what was going on my youngest Hope
was in the ICU for a few days in the
hospital for a little more than a week
she is back home and we are watching her
closely and she thanked her co-host
Savannah for her support when your child
is ill
the amount of gratitude you can have for
for people for who helped you out I'm
grateful to my family and I'm grateful
to friends like you who were there every
single day so I want to say thank you
for that I really I love you I love you
too the today anchor shares two children
with her ex Joel schiffman six-year-old
Haley and hope the former couple adopted
Haley in 2017 after Hoda's 2007 battle
with breast cancer left her unable to
conceive I always had this thing inside
me that just like it was a voice I
couldn't quiet
it was a voice that wanted to be a mom
but thought it was too late it was that
voice and I think you know you can push
a voice like that away for a long time
but sooner or later it comes back up
and you have to address it then two
years later Hoda and Joel adopted hope
we like the idea of of Haley not
um we want her to have a sibling because
she has such interesting circumstances
to grow up in any way so it would be
nice to be able to share it with
somebody while Haley and hope continue
growing together their parents decided
to go their separate ways last year amid
a personally challenging time Jenna had
nothing but praise for how Hoda handled
it I'm proud of Hoda every single day
she is filled with compassion and Grace
and she does everything that way I mean
I watch her come into the office every
morning smiling and every single person
she's treated me with such love and been
a mentor and now I'm a really dear
friend so it's no surprise she does
everything in life with Grace and
compassion
foreign